years ago i used to feel
[Music]
somewhat embarrassed that i was writing
comics i felt
there were men building bridges and
working in laboratories on cures for
illness and
but over the years i've learned how much
joy
these comic books have brought to people
and um i began to realize that
entertainment is very important
in people's lives i've always felt it
would be nice
if while enjoying the adventure if the
reader also
gets the feeling that we should all
be good to each other and
the world is a small place we only have
a short time
in it
[Music]
we tried to make our characters have
feet of clay now poor spider-man
i mean okay he's pretty good at catching
bad guys but he's have to get an allergy
attack while he's fighting he
worries about dandruff he'll have an
ingrown toenail tears his costume
you designed me in the room
[Laughter]
and my wife said to me you know stan if
you want to quit anyway
why don't you do the next book you do
the way
you want to do it just for fun the worst
that happens is you'll be fired
and you want to quit so what's the big
deal
if you have an idea that you
genuinely think is good don't let some
idiot talk you out of it
[Applause]
you know i guess one person can make a
difference
[Music]
enough said
and i figured i'm gonna tell you how
spider-man
came into being
it's it's a true story although
sometimes it's hard even for me to
believe it
but um we had already done the fantastic
four and i think maybe the x-men i can't
remember the order but my publisher came
to me
and he said stan i want you to come up
with another superhero
so i thought what power will i give a
new guy and i saw a fly
crawling on the wall and i said hey if i
could get a superhero
that could stick to walls and crawl on
him
man that would be cool and no i'm lying
to you
i don't think the word cool was in use
then i probably
i probably said it'll be groovy
so okay i had my hero i had his power
his name
and then i figured just for fun i'm
gonna give him
personal problems and then i thought i'd
make him a teenager
because there were no teenage
superheroes that i knew of at the time
so armed with all that wonderful
material
those great ideas i ran into my
publisher's office and i told them
this was my reaction the reaction he
gave me
stan that is the worst idea i have ever
heard
first of all and he started to give me
his because he's a very logical man very
intellectual
first of all people hate spiders
so you can't call a hero spiderman
you want him to be a teenager
teenagers can only be sidekicks
and you want him to have personal
problems
stan don't you know what a superhero is
they don't have personal problems
well i left the office disappointed but
obviously
a much wiser man
and i couldn't get spider-man out of my
system
so we were about to kill a magazine i
think it was called amazing fantasy
it wasn't selling well and we were
sending the last issue to press
when you do the last issue of a magazine
nobody cares what you're putting it
because the book is dying
just to get it out of my system i put
spider-man in amazing fantasy feature
them on the cover
forgot about it a month later all the
sales figures came in
my publisher came racing into my office
stand stan you remember that character
we both
loved so much spider-man
[Applause]
let's do them as a series now why am i
telling you this
besides the fact that i have to kill a
little time
if you have an idea that you
genuinely think is good don't let some
idiot talk you out of it
[Music]
now that doesn't mean that every wild
notion you come up with is going to be
genius
but if there is something that you feel
is good
something you want to do something that
means something to you
try to do it because i think you can
only do your best work
if you're doing what you want to do and
if you're doing it the way
you think it should be done and if you
can take pride in it after you've done
it
no matter what it is you can look at it
and say i did that and i think it's
pretty damn good
that's a great feeling so don't let
idiots talk you out of something that
you think is good
i try to think of the characters first
and i try to think what would make this
character interesting
let's say the character is a detective
all right there are millions of
detectives in movies and television and
novels
what can i do to make my detective
unique and stand out from all the others
and what can i do to make all the other
characters interesting to read about
the kind of people you'd like to know
because they're colorful
and so i'd write that down i'd write the
name of the character and what there is
about him or her that
i would find interesting i'd like to
think of myself as an
entertainer i i feel if i can entertain
people in any way it's very gratifying
because it's a funny thing years ago
i used to feel somewhat embarrassed that
i was writing comics i felt
there were men building bridges and
working in laboratories on
cures for illness and and doing real
things and i'm writing these comic books
but
over the years i've learned how much joy
these comic books have brought to people
and i began to realize that
entertainment is very important in
people's lives
most people almost everybody have lives
that have problems and troubles and
things to worry about and
if you can entertain somebody take his
or her mind off
the things that would normally be
bothering them
that's a good thing to do i'm probably
my own biggest fan
but as i always tell people who ask me
for tips on writing
i think what you have to do you have to
write to please yourself
i i never would write anything where i'd
say this will be good for people who are
30 years old or this would be good for
people in their teens
or all i ever think of is what would i
want to read what characters would
interest me
and i'm not that different from millions
of other people
if there's something i would like to
read there must be other people who'd
like to read
the same thing 100 from what you've
written
i would like to think that everything we
do in our stories
helps the readers to
to just understand the world and to have
a little more
tolerance and to take the peaceful and
intelligent route
instead of what some people do i've
always felt
it would be nice if while enjoying the
adventure
when you what is give me the definition
of what makes a good
superhero oh that's a tough question
and if i uh teach too many people i'm
gonna have a lot of competition but what
the hell
first of all you have to have a
character whether it's a superhero or
not that people care about
your lead character must be someone a
you can understand
b you can relate to and see that you
care about and you want to do well
he has to be written in such a way that
you wish he was a friend of mine
and if he were my friend i'd wish him
the best so you have to like spike oh
absolutely you have to like him as a
person
and too often people who do superhero
story
or any stories they get a lead character
but they forget to give them that one
likable or empathetic factor which is so
necessary as you know
well you got it i would like to think
that everything we do
in our stories helps the readers
to to just understand the world and to
have a little more tolerance
and to take the peaceful and intelligent
route
instead of what some people do i've
always felt
it would be nice if while enjoying the
adventure
if the reader also gets the feeling
that we should all be good to each other
and the world is a small place we only
have a short time in it
and we must make it as pleasant for
ourselves and for other people as we
possibly can
and doing the right thing is better than
doing the wrong thing
behind everything there should be a good
moral
tone i've always tried to put that in
they try to do that now with marvel and
i hope they keep doing that forever
hey you guys make love not war
my publisher had learned that dc
comics which was then called national
comics
had a book called the justice league and
it was selling very well
and it was made up of a number of
superheroes so he said to me stan
why don't you come up with a book with a
team of superheroes
and i really didn't want to do the same
old thing
with guys who just wear costumes and
masks and have secret identities
and and the girl is always a token
girl who has to be rescued all the time
in fact at that time i really wanted to
quit because i had been doing these
comics for about
20 years and they were
i had the same instructions for my
publisher all the time
don't use words of more than two
syllables
don't play up too much dialogue the
readers get bored reading dialogue and
so i felt i was just writing
one-dimensional stories
and my wife said to me you know stan if
you want to quit anyway
why don't you do the next book you do
the way you want to do it just for fun
the worst that happens is you'll be
fired
and you want to quit so what's the big
deal
and luckily that was when he asked me to
do this
team of superheroes so i thought how can
i make them a little different than
what had gone before one
no secret identity two the girl
is gonna be as much a valuable member of
the team as the other three guys
three i am
instead of the heroine not knowing that
the hero
is really a hero you know the clark
can't lose
lane's syndrome i'll let them be engaged
they know each other and they know what
they do and that's
it how do you how do you keep the
creative juices flowing
to keep creating work over the years
greed
is probably one of the reasons no
actually
i'm doing what i enjoy doing it's like
other men like to play golf
so they play golf every chance they can
so you don't say to him how come you're
playing golf today you played last week
was the same with me to me it is such
fun creating characters writing stories
even doing interviews even though i
can't hear most of what the guy says to
me
but it's an exciting life
and when you do something that you know
the fans seem to
enjoy that gives you such satisfaction
you don't want to stop
there was a character and it was owned
by fawcett and by disney there was
fighting over it
and we couldn't use the name but i
wanted
our name was marvel comics and i wanted
something with the word marvel in it
and we finally decided we made her a
female
i don't know i just decided to make her
a female
i can't remember why i thought
i like things that are different if you
do what everybody expects
you're just doing the ordinary but if
you surprise
people that's fun and i think people
were surprised to see that our captain
marvel was a female
so that was fun for me you know that is
probably the toughest question
i could ever think of to answer because
i don't
know what what i would do was just sit
back and try to think of something
i don't know that there's any
inspiration involved if
when i worked at marvel i worked for a
publisher
and for example when the fantastic force
sold
well he said oh maybe the fans like
groups of heroes come up with another
group
so i sat and i thought and i came up
with the x-men
but how i did it or i don't know i mean
i just tried to think of a group
and i probably thought of a number of
them where i said nah that's no good now
that's no good
in fact with the x-men i remember one of
the toughest things is coming up with
the super power how do they get their
superpower
and i had already had the fantastic four
get their power from cosmic rays
and i think daredevil got his from gamma
rays
and spider-man got his from a
radioactive spider and i was running out
of ideas
so i said hey i'll make a mutants
they're born that way and then i don't
need any new rays
but it's just a matter of thinking i
mean
you you sit and you think until the
right idea hits you right
there's no trick to it
you